this is a production of Cornell
University
here in the garden of the mecca voi
educational center 3 corn aliens came to
build a piece of community-minded living
sculpture with students to start the
planning process they made a list of
goals for the project and everyone
agreed creating a private and quiet
shaded space would draw community
members to the area to create this
contemplative space they built this
tunnel and dome from willow and dogwood
the design of these pieces is very nice
the dome sits within the curve of the
twisting tunnel and the entire space is
designed to maximize people's
interactions with the sculptures while
the layout of this piece is interesting
this sculpture is seen better days this
tunnel is creative using cuttings of
Willow and dogwood which were planted in
the ground in the hopes that they would
grow roots and survive this is a
difficult practice because fresh
cuttings require a lot of water and care
in order to become established the more
successful parts of the tunnel are made
from willows like this one which is
survived because of its thicker diameter
one of the strengths of living
sculptures the adaptability of its
components well this project may not
have turned out as planned this tunnel
and omar still effective because plants
like this beam vine and these sunflowers
are growing to fill in the gaps it can
be frustrating to work with living
materials but every project has the
potential to grow into something new
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu